but the
rock is cooking oh yeah i can smell what
he's cooking
the rock is cooking up free guacamole
for his birthday
and cinco de mayo here to tell us about
the block on the rock
and terramana tequila promotion is
master mixologist lynette marrero
welcome lumet lynette so tell us how do
we get
free guacamole all right well like you
said it is a celebration weekend for us
here at terra mana
so what you can do is you can go to guac
on the rock.com
you can also check out terramana.com
where you can look up locations we
actually have great locations in las
vegas we're going to be
offering this promotion so you can go to
benihana's chica las vegas
chayo mexican kitchen and tequila bar or
lucky day tequila mezcal bar
order our guacamole order your taramana
cocktails and then you're going to take
a photo of that receipt
upload it to the guac on the rock
website and you will get a venmo back
for up to ten dollars for your guacamole
purchase this is amazing and it actually
starts tomorrow because the rock's
birthday is sunday he turns 49 on sunday
the promotion starts tomorrow it goes
through cinco de mayo
how would you how would you describe the
rock's tequila brand
so what i would say is it's from the
highlands in in
jalisco so it's really has a beautiful
like notes of tropical fruit some nice
green aromas it is gluten free
it is sustainable um we use copper pot
stills so
it is a beautiful tequila and you're
going to start making the people's
margarita right now why did you get to
us and tell us what goes into one of the
most amazing margaritas the people's
margarita
all right so we're using agave nectar
we're using about a tablespoon of that
which is about a half ounce
and then i'm going to go ahead and put
my fresh lime juice in
you're going to use just three quarters
of an ounce or about a half of a lime in
there
real simple um then we add an ounce of
pineapple juice like i said you get some
of those tropical fruit aromas so you
really want to have
uh some of these kind of nice tropical
flavors uh to go ahead with that and
then
two ounces of our terramana blanco
tequila i like to
throw a pinch of salt in my margaritas
instead of having on the rim
and that just is a little trick you can
do and then you go ahead and just shake
that up
and pour it into your glass i like using
my nice big one big
rock for the right one big rock for the
rock this is perfect i love all the
connections that you guys have going on
that's right and then i like to garnish
i used fresh pineapple so i like
garnishing with a beautiful fresh
pineapple leaf
and maybe a lime but this is a nice
little twist a really refreshing
margarita beautiful but please check out
what your local restaurants are doing
because this is about community building
and getting restaurants back on their
feet so please enjoy
walk on the rock we'll do it thank you
so much lynette we appreciate it for
more information visit
guac on the rock dot com and las vegas
now will be